Israel's parliament has passed the first
reading of a controversial Bill to
overhaul the Judiciary it if it becomes
law Parliament would be able to strike
down Decisions by the Supreme Court with
a simple majority it'll lead to pass a
second and third reading in Parliament
let's go live now to West Jerusalem I'll
just hear us Imran Khan is there for us
Imran tell us more about this bill and
why there's so much opposition to it
well the bill is very very controversial
because it basically allows uh for the
kinesid to make all of the decision
decisions it wants to make without any
form of second house now if you take the
UK for example or the American political
system you have the Senate you have the
House of Lords and they have the ability
to try and stop the House of Commons
from having too much power effectively
that's the Supreme Court here uh the
Supreme Court sort of fills that role so
by stripping away their powers people
are saying that it's going to become an
illiberal a democracy a more Hungarian
style democracy that it's going to give
unprecedented powers to the knesset and
the people who support the government
now it also it wasn't just the bill that
you just mentioned there's a few bills
that passed as part of the judicial
Reform Bill uh bill that they want to
pass now the other section of that was
uh taking away the Supreme Court's
ability to decide whether the prime
minister is fit for office now the prime
minister right now Benjamin Netanyahu
has three court cases against him so
this is seen as a politically motivated
uh Bill passing that they're trying to
do now like you said it goes to a second
and a third reading if it gets to a
third reading your position is likely to
boycott the vote completely so the first
reading is crucial because it advances
the bill but it will be the third
reading there will be uh absolutely
crucial because that's the real test of
whether the Coalition uh the government
will hold stand firm and try and pass
the bill that will then become law we've
seen unprecedented protests but as we
say the bill has passed its first
reading what now for the protest
movement
difference
well like I say the first reading is
absolutely crucial because it advances
the bill in Parliament and that's going
to Galvanize and get more people out on
the streets of the protest movement now
there's a protester going to happen on
Thursday they were already calling it a
day of escalation but you just have to
take a look at social media uh in
reaction to this they want more people
out on the streets now uh on Saturday
night the usual night for the protesters
Israel had half a million people on the
streets that's the biggest protest uh
numbers that we've seen in the country's
history 200 000 of those were in Tel
Aviv 50 000 were in Haifa that's a huge
amount of people for Haifa such a small
place so it's likely that this bill will
get more and more people out onto the
streets on Saturday night on Thursday
they'll want to get their voice heard
it's also um pushing Israeli
institutions key Israeli institutions
like the Israeli Army to the brink the
reservists are refusing to come in for
their Duty that's becoming a problem
because having an impact on operational
capacity for Israel so what we've got
here now we've got a situation where
you've got key institutions who are now
joining the protest movement and that's
going to weaken Israel's security so
that's alarming uh for the state of
Israel itself but more importantly than
that you've got Civil Society members
from all uh sections of society joining
in and that voice will get heard it just
takes a few people within the coalition
government to go these are huge numbers
maybe I should pay attention for the
coalition to fall apart I'll just hear a
Imran Khan reporting live from West
Jerusalem Imran many thanks indeed